I got jokes hold up oh
my God
where are you right now I might be able
to support it is
ah
[Music]
that is adorable
let me joke bro
[Laughter]
you got you guys watch the new Jeffrey
Dahmer yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I heard um he was doing uh he was doing
um an interview said it was the hardest
role
he ever played he has to play in his
life yeah
it'd be really hard to play a gay guy
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa whoa
it'll be real
Market Market
it would be funny I have a career I have
a movie out now I can't be out there
saying all that kind of [__] Flex on
these broke [__] bro I was
trying to flex Flex on them I gotta move
you out damn I'd literally just being
honest we were in the movie theater no
big deal that's what it is Tribeca Film
Festival no big deal
[__] waiting outside
oh yeah 824 yeah yes yes
dog they don't miss they were excited
outside that's all I have to say yeah
that was her name that was her name
bro
[Laughter]